we get to Hong Kong I just want to talk
to you about the US and the protests
that we've seen in the United States we
just heard there Dominic Rob the Foreign
Secretary's saying he doesn't want to be
drawn on the tweets that were sent by
the US President Donald Trump saying
that if the protesters had breached the
White House they would have been greeted
with the most vicious dogs and the most
ominous weapons I've ever seen and
earlier this week tweeting when the
looting starts the shooting starts do
you think this is acceptable language
from the president well I have to say
the people I've been listening to other
community leaders in Atlanta Georgia I
don't know if you heard yesterday but
there was a musician who was speaking
about the courage required by the
Atlanta police officers in order to
defuse this violence and I have to say
the Atlanta Police Chief when she went
out and spoke to the crowds I thought
was inspirational and so it's easy to
focus on one person in an event like
this and I accept this is the president
of the United States and therefore
you're not wrong to pay particular
attention to him but the reality is the
United States is a very very diverse
society you know there are many people
who have authority of different levels
and a few as you know already Sophie
because you're a bit of a
constitutionalist the the president
doesn't actually have executive
authority in areas like this and so I'm
listening to the to the local leaders
and this is a particularly tragic
situation where many many black
Americans African Americans have been
murdered in in various different ways
over many many years and and clearly the
frustrations are very very real and so I
think looking at how local police chiefs
and local governors are resolving it I
think is it can actually be more
inspirational than the federal
government that doesn't have the
authority okay and now I'm keen to talk
about Hong Kong because this week trying
to pass a new law that many seres
effectively ending Hong Kong's
independence and how concerned are you
by what you're saying and is the UK
government doing enough well many it was
a very concern it won't surprise you to
hear I've been in touch with the
committee chairs of Parliament's around
the world and a lot of us are raising
issues with our own government because
this isn't just
about the UK although we have a
particular responsibility under the
sino-british joint declaration it's
actually about the rule of law in global
trade it's about the rights of free
people to free assembly in freedom of
speech this isn't this isn't just about
Hong Kong it's about China living up to
the commitments that it's made and given
that China is you know now a major quite
understandably and quite rightly a major
global player you know second largest
economy in the world one of them sorry
the most populous country in the world
it's really important that we know where
the China is going to live up to the
promises that it made or not and that's
why this is more than about Hong Kong
it's about all of us dealing with an
authoritarian state that has decided to
tear up the rules you talking about
China tearing up the rules and certainly
the actions are trying to come under the
spotlight recently when it comes to Hong
Kong but also of course on its handling
of the corona virus pandemic you've
called China a tyranny do you think the
UK's approach and relationship to China
needs to change yes I do think it needs
to change you know tyranny is not an
insult it's a simple description of a
country that does not have any form of
genuine popular representation it's it's
a state decided by the will of the party
and nothing else indeed it the party has
its own courts like an aristocracy and
all those de Grassi in in a medieval
sense really so it's you know it's got a
very very authoritarian system of
government and I think the UK needs to
realize that and rethink the
partnerships that we've made now that's
why I'm very pleased that actually
number 10 is now reviewing our
dependence on Hong Kong and according to
The Sunday Times today is reviewing our
agreement to bring while way into our 5g
networks so I think there's a lot of
positive now coming from the government
I'm delighted that the China research
group that I chair as well as the
Foreign Affairs Committee has put a bit
of pressure on the government to to help
make that happen but you know there are
really good examples of countries that
we can learn from partner with and you
know if you look around the region in
South Korea and Japan also looking to
stand up to
Chinese pressure and of course no Taiwan
which is a Chinese democracy let's not
forget that democracy is not individual
to China it's simply the communist
tyranny has ruled it for 70 years you
know there are options here how we how
we look again at at our relationship now
I'm keen to get your thoughts on another
story that's really been dominating the
agenda this week and that is Dominic
Cummings we heard there from the foreign
secretary Dominic Robb who seem to imply
that he wasn't aware that mr. Cummings
was in Durham when he was acting Prime
Minister do you think that's a problem
well this is clearly dominated the
agenda for ages you'll forgive me I've
been focusing on areas like Hong Kong
with you as you heard and I'm also
particularly conscious as a local MP
that businesses in my in the area that
I'm privileged enough to represent are
about to come out of furlough and about
to have to stop paying more for their
staff and they're about to find
themselves in a very very difficult
economic position the Chancellor ashisu
knack has been incredibly clear about
the economic challenges we face and I
know the businesses around the country
large and small are going to be looking
very hard at the options they may have
to take now given that we're going to be
facing a major economic challenge and
that may sadly mean unemployment and
business failure I'd really like to get
on with focusing on how the economy is
held together and building on the very
very good work that Ricci sunic has done
to avoid the most layoffs that we've
seen in places like the United States
nicely sidestepped and but mr. Dominic
Cummings and you know this conservatives
have seen their poll lead
dramatically cut in the last week MPs
had been complaining of being inundated
with letters from constituents even
Theresa May has spoken out to her
constituents saying that she understands
people's frustrations there is this
doing real damage to your party so if
you of course I'm sidestepping it the
reason I'm sidestepping it is because
I'm not in government I'm not going to
answer for the government I'm not going
to defend a government in that way the
Prime Minister has made his decision you
know you can see the effect on it you
don't need me to tell you you can see
how people have reacted to it and I've
written
people I'm privileged enough to
represent to give them my views sorry
what did you say well I said I said I
can understand the frustration but it's
fundamentally up to the Prime Minister
and you know and it's going to be up to
all of us to to express our views so I
passed on the views of many constituents
to the Prime Minister and I passed on my
own views but this is not the first time
I've had moments of frustration with my
government as you know something I don't
I don't always agree with everything
that the administration does but I
really do think that the purpose of our
government any government in fact is to
serve the interests of the people not to
get wrapped up in in HR disputes and
here I really think that the thing that
we've got to do if the Prime Minister is
adamant that he wishes to keep an
advisor or not fine that's that
fundamentally is their decision and they
have to bear the consequences of it but
what I really want to see them doing is
to making sure that we work to deliver
an economy that works for as many you
know as many businesses as possible
that's not going to be everybody now
that's that that's the real challenge
here the real challenge is that actually
the economy is turning and we need to
make sure that we get it back as you
know as well as possible to toe growth
and that's gonna be a huge challenge
when already we know that there are
economic challenges around the world
because of coronavirus already we know
that the implications of our deals with
China are going to have an effect on
some aspects of our business and we know
as well that you know we are now what
six seven months away from leaving the
European Union and whether you wrote it
to leave all to remain everybody knows
that tearing up trade agreements has
consequences and this one will too so I
think there are huge numbers of things
that this government really needs to be
getting on with now and if you wish to
discuss personal the number-10 forgive
me I suggest you ask somebody who works
in number 10